m
[Musique]
enfin le port de roscoff se dévoile tout
entier
depuis plusieurs jours les bateaux resté
cloué à quai la mer était bien trop
dangereuse
ce matin enfin le vent s'est calmé le
brouillard dissiper le temps est venu de
reprendre la mer
jean va
et c'est là pays
[Musique]
dans le soleil levant les pêcheurs
largue les amarres pour se mettre en
quête du plus précieux des crustacés
[Musique]
solitaire fier et belliqueux le homard
est un roi en mer comme dans nos
assiettes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
longtemps il est resté un produit de
luxe que l'on rêvait d'avoir sur nos
tables les jours de fête aujourd'hui
tout le monde en passe pour ce homard
les français en ont consommé 4500 tonnes
l'année dernière et la pêche sur nos
côtes ne suffit plus à répondre à la
demande
alors la france se met à importer du
homard il vient du canada ou des états
unis là bas on empêche maintenant 160
mille tonnes chaque année ses 80 fois
plus que la production européenne
alors entre le homard bleu breton et son
cousin orange d'amérique lequel faut-il
choisir
la consommation de masse est elle en
train de changer le produit fait elle
peser des risques sur l'espèce
le goût de notre homard est il toujours
le même
pour le savoir
nous avons remonté la filière jusqu'à
l'autre bout de l'océan
nous avons suivi les traces
du mieux carrossée de tous les crustacés
[Musique]
c'est omar claude la pêcher toute sa vie
comme son père avant lui à 60 ans il
continue à sortir presque tous les jours
ce métier c'est sa passion et celle de
son meilleur ami daniel est ici on vend
parfois le matin systématiquement on ne
peut pas le fort c'est suivant le
suivant les maris
on est obligé de combiner défend parc à
dover des fours par à 10 heures départ à
6 heures ça dépend des salles et pour
les marseillais marc egly commandement
chef chouan way
c
pas la pêche mais m en 73
1901 papier
comme ça il y a
je désire o'neill
à quelques milles de l'île de batz où il
est né et claude met le cap à l'est
c'est là que se trouvent les meilleures
troupes à omar
mais bon le homard souvent ils longent
attendant il est en train de servir la
roche et quand il fait beau il va sur le
sable se promener des fois attends rien
n'est décidé donc moi c'est ma cas je
vois une roche je mets une petite croix
comme ça je sais à peu près où sont tous
les roches
quand je filme et casiers j'essaie de
passer sous les roues si les croix jésus
maca est bon j'essaie de passer sur ecm
et razik des fois ça tombe bien des fois
ça tombe à côté à cause du courant
c'est le petit bonheur la chance
là ça va servir
dans la baie claude et daniel disposant
tout d'une centaine de casiers
[Musique]
à
par contre
réf
[Musique]
il ya huit ans
nous fûmes
[Musique]
toutefois deux
il ya
donc là il est beaucoup trop petit
depuis 2002 claude doit remettre à l'eau
de poules et homards dont le thorax
mesure moins de 87 mm des règles visant
à préserver l'espèce de la surpêche
il est temps de rentrer lire
[Musique]
parce que c'est toi
à
et enfin on n'empêche qu'ils ont d'eux
de septembre puisque
karine donc
30 réserve et fait pas beau omettre le
casino
pour les heures au temple
et ce jour là la pêche n'est pas très
bonne claude et daniel ne ramasseront
qu'une quarantaine de homard ce sont des
animaux aussi rares que précieux une
sorte de trésors de la mer pour ceux qui
les pêchent
c'est le roi des coachs à celle allant
vous salue en mars
auj
[Musique]
on s est vus beaux leurs marques
50e par guillaume ahond 3
le reste c'est quoi
ces moments réchapper
[Musique]
une autre région française a longtemps
fait du homard son étendard c'est la
charente maritime
aujourd'hui pourtant le crustacé il ya
presque disparu
[Musique]
dans cette école de l'île de ré cet
après midi les enfants assistent à un
cours donné par des écogardes
l'objectif c'est qu'ils se réapproprient
une partie de leur patrimoine
tu ne rajoutait pas tout blanc revenons
bien fallu rajouter de plantation marins
les fourrières 1 2 3 4 qui porte la
grande pince et qu'il a tout ce qu'il
faut non pas le recouvrir
alors donc c'était l'idée de la grande
île d'un grand livre accordéon qui peut
ce qui peut se replier et donc tout le
milieu aquatique va rencontrer le homard
donc avec les dorades
vraiment toute la faune et la flore qui
a autour de l'île de ré
les enfants vont voir un bébé aux
marques et un jour par sortir du sable
et va devoir côtoyer tous est aussi
stable
donc est ce qu'il va être bien là en
dessous le rocher en dessous line bah
oui parce que de l'avoir trouvé de la
nourriture s'il va être cachée par l'ags
donc il est pas mal est-ce que ça nage
un homard oui ça peut nager mais sa vie
surtout
dans le sable sur le fond
on est ce là allez on va le cacher
ici beaucoup découvrent un animal qu'ils
n'ont jamais vu de leurs propres yeux et
pour que ce soit plus concret encore la
classe participe à un programme de
réintroduction
adopte un homard c'est le nom du
programme et chaque enfant a dû choisir
le nom de son petit crustacé
il y a
la piscine
nous avions les pins
[Musique]
les voici diamant nina zelda capucine et
les autres dans les sous sols de
l'aquarium de la rochelle fabienne le
gall et son équipe déco garde sont en
train de les préparer pour le grand jour
faut il nous faut moins de coleson way
trouver les petits homards a fait une
opération un petit peu technique et donc
kim est un petit peu de temps puisqu'il
faut les blés pour vase et
individuellement qu'en club à quatre
personnes il nous faut à peu près 3 4
heures
fabienne le gall est à l'initiative d'un
projet de réintroduction des homards
unique en france en tout elle et ses
collègues vont relâcher trois mille
bébés en haute mer cet après midi puis
c'est cette année et bien on a rencontré
des pêcheurs sinisé qu'il trouvait de
moins en moins de constater - de tout au
moins deux araignées
quasiment plus de romain est en fait à
partir de ces observations qu'on a
commencé à se poser aussi des questions
donc on a fait de la bibliographie de
façon à en voir effectivement quels
étaient les retours au niveau
scientifique par rapport à ces
populations de romain effectivement
c'est quand même très fragile ces
petites bêtes qui mesure à peine 2 cm
donc effectivement elles sont très
sensibles
moindre changement de température de
l'eau au moindre changement de salinité
à peuvent très facilement mourir
pourtant ces crustacés ont déjà fait un
long voyage
avant d'arriver jusqu'ici ils sont nés
en angleterre dans une écloserie
s'il semble bien minuscule ils ont déjà
tous des grands
les pins sont bien faites
en fait elles sont les jolies
les baies l'antenne
dynamique
celui-là on le reverra ah oui
[Musique]
encore les enfants sont venus dire adieu
à leurs petits homards
qu'est ce que tu me tiens c'est plus on
croit détient lequel tu
choisirais accessible à tous
[Musique]
les homards vont maintenant voyager sur
ce bateau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
seront libérés dans une zone protégée
située au nord de l'île de ré
par cette équipe de plongeurs bénévoles
[Musique]
c'est important que l'on pose bien la
boîte aux verts le fond que vous ouvriez
à ce moment là quand la boîte laquelle
la boîte est bien posée ou vers le fond
et qu'il y a un petit peu de sable à
proximité parce que les petits homards
ils ont besoin de se faire un petit abri
en sable
ranger dans les camemberts c'est l'heure
du grand plongeon pour les petits
crustacés ils vont découvrir l'océan
délicatement ils sont descendus à vingt
mètres de fond
avant de prendre leur envol
dans cinq ans ils parviennent à éviter
les prédateurs qui sévissent à ces
profondeurs
ils seront alors de ben omar
de taille adulte
[Musique]
ben nous on aimerait que ces populations
de homard soit plus prospères et puis
qu'on puisse retrouver de nouveau des
homards dans les casiers l'association
donc on espère toujours fermés un petit
coup de pouce à la nature
lentement les trois mille bébés omar
vont se disperser au gré du courant avec
l'espoir pour les scientifiques de
redonner vie à une espèce en danger sur
ses côtes françaises
[Musique]
le homard pourtant à son royaume
il est situé ici
de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
[Musique]
à shediac au canada on a même fait de
lui
l'emblème de la ville
dans ce pays qui est devenu depuis les
années 90 le premier producteur mondial
de homard on le chérit y on le fait
dans le golfe du nouveau brunswick ce
jour là plus de mille personnes sont
réunies pour un immense banquet sans vie
d'un bébé vous allez servile de bons
moments la conafe triplement du 68e
festival du homard de shediac
en ce jour de juillet on célèbre
l'ouverture de la saison de la pêche
ici tout le monde est dingue du homard
le maire de shediac en tête
[Musique]
tu es le meilleur remarque j'ai jamais
vu
les romans les plus est est plus
important que le maire
vous savez ça fait soixante huit ans un
pur conciliables c'est ce festival
annuel semaine énormément de retombées
économiques
c'est un festival de tradition
au mot décision
expliquera finalement ça va mal
en cinq jours dix mille omar vont être
engloutis dans cette ambiance de fête
foraine et sans pincettes
on a conduit pendant 14 heures pour
venir à shediac pour profiter du
festival du homard et pour en manger
bien sûr
le homard c'est pour moi et l'autre doc
c'est pour mon mari c'est parfait comme
ça je n'ai pas besoin de partager avec
eux
8 euros pour un homard entier à peine
plus pour un sandwich au homard le
crustacé se mange comme dans un fast
food on peut même le dévorer au concours
de mangeurs de homard
compliqué c'est trois mandats trois
minutes et puis vous ne devez utiliser
aucun outil bout du pq lisez vos mains
vos coups de pied
tout
ça avant de nous
je lis tous leurs amis que les picards
je suis sans doute
tous les goûts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que l'on peut goûter non pas
de déguster vraiment la chair dont moi
mais je veux dire ça mais continue 68ème
festival normand cepos on a posé le
déguster aussi dit je sais que ça couine
le
ouais
à shediac le homard attire les touristes
mais il fait surtout vivre la région et
ses 800 pêcheurs tout le reste de
l'année
le ciel orangé de l'été indien annonce
l'ouverture de cette nouvelle saison de
pêche
dès la tombée de la nuit les équipages
s'affairent pour le départ
jean pierre cormier et pêcheurs de
homard depuis 14 ans
il est maintenant 2 heures du matin
lui et son équipage font route vers le
large
mais les normands et toujours
on les a annulé tout ça
au journal et dounia monde
non
[Musique]
s'il s'en va
si le sang
oui je
[Musique]
il rend grâce à dieu je c'est ce n'est
fait je lucratif
amis du jeu cinquante photos à bronzer
un jour bep j à l'année
il est indécent parce qu'il y avait vu
le lien
justin certains hôtels au monde
tu peux juste ramos intéressante à mon
tour
vous la survie de la consommation
pour jean pierre et ses 600 concurrents
c'est une course éprouvante qui démarre
elle va durer neuf semaines seulement la
durée de cette saison de pêche
cette nuit ils ont 250 casier a levé le
rythme est intense pour une pêche qu'ils
espèrent bien miraculeuse agressive à
manger mais aussi de
bessèges puis champion derrière
[Musique]
leur maladie c'est de la crs moussa qui
en tombe de nouveau
je sais que nous serons parce que rien
d'aléatoire quilès
et tous et omar ne finiront pas dans nos
assiettes
parmi ceux qui restent coincés au fond
du casier
certains vont être relâchés
immédiatement
seule la manche alors toujours pas que
cela
[Musique]
après l'avoir avant des petits c'est
interdit aux lapins tour
[Musique]
jean pierre travaille avec son père guy
ils connaissent les moindres recoins de
la baie et les risques du métier l'année
dernière quatre pêcheurs ont perdu la
vie en mer c'est dû à l'audio les ventes
traduit si t'as pas le coup d'oeil toi
tu te revient pas
c'est animé la semaine passée à l'est
j'avais envie d'être à sortir la cadence
du train parce que tous ensemble les
gens le capitaine a commencé la boue et
tout de suite il importe offerts
incluent héritage prêt l'année
de sa voix
je trouvais la langue
c'est un poids souvent servi
ils vont passer dix heures à lever des
casiers
jusqu'au lendemain matin
jusqu'à ce que le soleil se lève
[Musique]
qui a 70 ans et il sort en mer depuis
l'âge de 6 ans il a vu la pêche au
homard se développer et rapidement il a
senti la nécessité de réglementer cette
activité
1971 quand j'ai commencé j'avais petit
fond mais kg pour toi 16 ans cette année
on avait deux mais qu'il est la première
forme d
une clause de valence si je mets jamais
battu avec des groupes majeurs c'est un
combat après les faits à quelque chose
puis on volley résulteront lui valentin
vrai
[Musique]
ce que les pêcheurs ont mis en place ce
sont des mesures très strictes une
réduction des périodes de pêche des
restrictions pour le nombre de licences
et puis surtout un programme massif de
réintroduction de l'espèce
six cent mille bébés omar ont été lâchés
dans ces eaux l'année dernière
dernier tour aux années de 3,4
[Musique]
grâce aux efforts de toute la filière
les eaux du golfe du saint-laurent
abrite de plus en plus de monstres comme
celui ci
de retour au port
jean-pierre va livrer le fruit de sa
pêche au comptoir des usines
et pour décharger ce jour là
mieux vaut avoir des bras dont ses
caisses le butin de cette nuit de pêche
1400 omar pour jean-pierre cela
représente un chiffre d'affaires de 4000
euros il a le sourire
la pêche c'est tellement
scandaleux cette année c'est la
mécanique est moins jusqu'à
l'année dernière cette activité a
rapporté plus de 600 millions d'euros à
l'économie canadienne
les populations de homard sont aussi
importants aujourd'hui que la saison de
pêche pourrait être prochainement
prolonger de plusieurs semaines
le lendemain matin à 5h30 des
silhouettes rejoignent l'unique bâtiment
éclairé de la ville
celle usine de transformation des
homards en pleine saison elle emploie
250 personnes et tournent 24 heures sur
serge est un des gérants de lusine
pendant les neuf semaines de pêche lui
non plus ne ferme pas beaucoup l'oeil
aujourd'hui ils réceptionnent 90000 omar
et c'est je vérifie la qualité du homard
bien sûr qui est bien vivant
le moment est vraiment beau ils viennent
directement du pendjab
tu peux pas avoir plus frais
[Musique]
les homards sont cuits sur place à un
rythme effréné
3000 kilos chaque heure
[Musique]
ils sont ensuite refroidi dans ces
énormes cuves
puis l'avait aux genôts
oui
avant qu'une armée de petites mains
prennent le relais
[Musique]
c'est destiné pour les états unis tous
les restaurants pour enlever la peinture
que la viande soit enlevé 100% bonne
qualité c'est à la main et les dames sur
des pattes il saura plus près d'un celi
de pacte à peu près 12 kg de prêtres
alors
j'assurerai pour faire sur qui on enlève
la viande la qualité du roman
la façon qu'il est con ce n'a pas été et
pas de la pac soit un maçon
cette chair de homard
c'est le nouveau best-seller de la
maison
un paquet de 900 grammes prêts à être
consommés
des pinces uniquement les parties les
plus raffinés du homard
il fait la fierté de serge
et de son frère aîné gilles
car cette entreprise est avant tout une
histoire de famille
ça y est c'est fait
les frères sur la troisième génération a
dirigé lusine le homard ils ont dans la
peau
c'est vraiment c'est spécial ça car
à cause c'est ma vie c'est ma passion
j'ai lu au monde est un moment mon grand
père mon père je suis dit on est une
famille le parler du vent la famille se
borne à monnières le banc lombard
léger plancher on a vécu
rossi ensemble les gens c'est important
l'entreprise shediac lobster shop a été
fondée par son grand-père en 1946
à l'époque c'est un simple comptoir en
bois sur le bord de la route la grand
mère de gilles yvan les homards et son
époux fait du porte à porte dans les
villages
soixante dix ans plus tard
la boutique est devenue une usine qui
exportent partout dans le monde
al étage gilles a rendez vous avec
daniel son responsable commercial
ensemble ils veulent faire le point sur
le potentiel de leurs nouveaux produits
à l'international lors
notre marché américain on est assez bien
établie oms a établi en chine l'an
dernier 1 on a notre marché japonais
mais notre client potentiel pour lui
rend il m'envoyait un email puis comme
tu peux voir
il est très intéressé de commencer avec
un plein quand tes mains pour la france
c'est nous autres on a une grosse
capacité je pense que comme le parlement
européen est on pour vraiment une grosse
grosse capacité donc avec notre charmant
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait avoir
sur les étagères à l'année
et c'est avec ces nouveaux paquets de
chair de homard décortiqué que gilles
prévoit de conquérir l'hexagone
sur le monde connaît c'est comment on
est fier aux morts puis on se déplace on
vient en france évoquant des revenus de
moi car la baguette française la france
il en vend des millions par jour des
baguettes française un bon grog selon
d'une baguette française ça serait un
saint louis jazz
qui seraient élevés ce serait
françois regarder
gille et daniel décident d'envoyer à
leurs clients français un premier
container treize mille kilos de homard
venue de shediac vont bientôt débarquer
à paris
plus jeune des deux frères exporte
aujourd'hui 95% de ses produits
[Musique]
ces crustacés arriveront un jour à paris
ici même sur le plus grand marché de
produits frais au monde rungis
[Musique]
chaque année plus de 97 milles tonnes de
poissons et de crustacés y transitent
[Musique]
wilfred chanel et est ce que tu sais où
il est le camion avec le homard
on les attend avec impatience ses des
homards qui viennent de boston ou de new
york
par un vol air france qui arrive sur
charles de gaulle marie-laure coudron et
annaëlle le goffic attendent
impatiemment leur cargaison elles sont
acheteuses chez le premier distributeur
de produits de la mer en france chaque
jour elle achète entre 900 et 2000 omar
montrer la palette de homard donc le
homard us dans nos achats ça représente
à peu près on va dire 60% c'est un peu
plus de la moitié par rapport au homard
bleu ou au maroc bretons
alors ça c'est des colis de 8 kg de
homard céder aux mains half qui font
entre 650 grammes et 800 grammes
voilà des idées au ps donc la coque est
bien dur c'est de voir qu'ils sont bien
vivants ils ont été pêchés hier en
quatre jours à peu près donc ça fait 96
heures donc c'est des boîtes alvéolées
ou les homards sont dessous donc ce ne
sont pas écrasés par le transport et le
voyage de ces crustacés n'est pas
terminée dans quelques heures ils vont
repartir aux quatre coins de la france
chez des grossistes ou des poissonniers
mais aussi depuis quelques temps chez
des restaurateurs d'un nouveau genre
tout ce qui
par lobster barre
comme ça qu'on voit sur la région
dix principales mots on va effectivement
il ya un engouement il ya un peu plus de
il ya un peu plus de demandes pour faire
des des commandes des restaurants à
thème où on mange du homard sous toutes
ses déclinaisons effectivement ça se
voit de plus en plus à paris les homards
sont en train de devenir les plus
branchés des crustacés
la vague du lobster roll le sandwich au
homard est en train de déferler sur la
capitale
des lobster barre des bars à omar ouvre
les uns après les autres une chaîne
vient même de faire son apparition
celui qui a flairé cette tendance
s'appelle rémy bouche l'eau il vient
d'ouvrir ce restaurant sont troisièmes à
paris
sur la carte de rémy deux plats et un
prix unique 25 euros pour un produit qui
garde une image haut de gamme
[Musique]
typiquement la démocratisation du moment
je vois beaucoup avec lobster rolls
royce est un sandwich de homard mettre
en avant ce but ça va être très bizarre
aux etats unis le font depuis des
décennies nous arrive tout juste en
france on est quelques restos à faire ça
et c'est une vraie manière de
démocratiser le produit le transformer
en loi d'un peu de jeunes kg en fumée
fast food et
pour aller un peu dans la folie du
burger et ben là c'est un beau regard
mais avec du marbre senna
tu viens on va d omar
sakho on peut remettre dedans ligne et
on va en mettre 2
avant le service rémy réceptionne sa
matière première des homards tout juste
arrivé du canada
est en train de mettre une partie des
lots marcon a reçu aujourd'hui dans le
vivier
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir les
conserver parce qu'on vient de livrer
tous les deux jours donc ce congrès dans
le vivier ils seront servis donc soit
soit demain soit dimanche
et puis on en fait partir une partie
directement en cuisine pour pour les
consommer ce soir
le principe du restaurant c2c proposer
un homard démocratiser ces remarques et
qui effraie vous pouvez le voir mais qui
n'est pas très cher donc vous proposant
marc feret à 25 euros du coup nous on
est le mar estang un produit très très
cher on est obligé de surfer sur les
différents courts du homard
soit on prend du breton soit de
l'américain soit du canadien l'idée
étant qu'on essaie nous de nous y
retrouver dans les prix et du coup le
canadien en ce moment une très bonne
qualité et il n'est pas très cher
et dans les cuisines en effet aucune
trace du homard breton l'objectif ici
c'est d'acheter le homard le moins cher
possible pour tirer les prix vers le bas
en cuisine centrale sont commis travail
au rythme d'une chaîne de fast food
hop
center sont les ouvriers les recettes
sont simples et rapides
par rapport au prix du vent le plat
c'est vrai que 108 renoncera pas à deir
ezzor vous interrogez n'importe quel
restaurateurs et là vous dire que c'est
très faible nous l'idée c'est que avec
ce prix très attractifs on essaie
d'attirer beaucoup de gens et ça nous
permet en fait de
avec le volume généré de la marge
tendance
thème est choisi ouais première de hall
entier gouvernement
au quai d'orsay
la parole à la normale
finition
les en excellence les yeux
simeoni
pour le déguster un tablier en plastique
une ambiance détendue l'objectif du
patron c'est de conquérir de nouveaux
clients plus jeunes
au site
voix qui ressemble
le quartier
et rémy ne va pas s'arrêter là il songe
à ouvrir un quatrième restaurants en
province cette fois
[Musique]
son succès il le doit au homard canadien
le homard us american us et le nom de
l'espèce pour arriver chez nous il lui
faut quatre jours il parcourt 4800 km
mais reste pourtant 20 à 30% moins cher
une fois sur nos étals c'est un produit
de consommation de masse les vrais
amateurs du goût choisiront toujours le
homard breton le homard us gamarus
également appelé homard bleu sa
fraîcheur du à sa proximité et le goût
de sa chair incomparable
[Musique]
le homard est bel et bien en train de se
démocratiser
dans ce supermarché de la région
parisienne sébastien cassagne le chef du
rayon poissonnerie on a même fait son
produit d'appel
chaque semaine dans son bureau il
compare les cours des différentes
espèces de homard pour s'approvisionner
au meilleur prix nous on fait nos
produits on les achète à la centrale
dont une centrale d'achat qui
travaillent avec nous donc ils achètent
d'abord au préalable et tout au tout la
majorité des poissons des crustacés et
tout est regroupé et ensuite après nous
on n'a plus qu'à aller sur le site et
choisir ce qu'on veut comme on entre
donc sur un homard breton que je vais
acheter 25 euros 36 je vais le revendre
32 90 donc du coup je ferais
18,68 % de marge sachant que les
magasins préconise 35 points dimanche on
va gagner notre père nation si je devais
vendre kadéos m'a offert ma boutique
en conclusion le homard chez nous ça
sert plutôt à attirer la clientèle
plutôt qu'à de faire du chiffre
d'affaires et c'est pour cela que le
chef de rayon propose ce matin les deux
espèces de crustacés à des prix défiant
toute concurrence
6 9 euros pour ce canadien de 600
grammes à gauche et 21 euros pour ce
breton à droite
et européens- sont plus affinée tout au
son plus affinée au son puissant on va
dire sont plus minières tandis que cela
au niveau de la tête sur un peu plus
gonflé
[Musique]
sa mort je préfère que le prix est
raisonnable aujourd'hui j'adore ça j'en
mange toute la nuit les tournages on
achète
c'est pas plus cher de l'avion
et moi je ne mange pas bien longue c'est
mon grand plaisir
aujourd'hui les ventes en france
représente 13 millions d'euros chaque
année avec une période phare pour tous
les poissonniers les fêtes de fin
d'année
le homard il est considéré pratiquement
comme le dieu de la mer il et pression'
ans donc si on n'a que du fils et du
poisson le rayon il est parrainé par
l'epa festif leur bassin produit festif
c'est comme les citrouilles pour
halloween s'il ya pas de mains sur les
tables de fêtes de fin d'année et après
des ventes qui s'envole et des prix qui
explosent
pendant la période de noël et du jour de
l'an le kg jusqu'à 70 euros c'est là que
se font la moitié des ventes annuel de
homards
alors pour ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens
il reste le rayon d'un côté et le
produit en tête des ventes de soupes
depuis des années
c'est la bisque de homard
sur les boîtes de jolis crustacés bien
rouge mais si l'on prend le temps de
déchiffrer les étiquettes ici seulement
12% de concentré de homard
sur cette autre marque cette bourse ont
à peine
le homard fait vendre mais il est cher à
mettre en boîte
bien sûr nous avons voulu interroger les
industriels sur ses pratiques
aucun d'entre eux n'a accepté de nous
ouvrir ses portes
pour connaître la vraie recette de la
bisque nous sommes donc retournés sur la
côte atlantique
sur un petit caillou
battus par les ombres
m
l'île de groix au large de la côte du
morbihan a longtemps été un port de
pêche important
[Musique]
c'est que le dernier gros a été le
premier port thonier en france sur une
île qui fait à 8 km par trois
on a du mal à imaginer le nombre de
bateaux qui arrivait dans le port de
groix petit à petit les cinq conserverie
qui était à cette époque sur l'île ont
fermé et aujourd'hui on est la dernière
en activité avec une vraie volonté et
donc de faire perdurer l'activité parce
qu'un vrai patrimoine culinaire sur
groix
marianne guyader est à la tête de groix
et nature la petite pme créée par son
père il ya 17 ans chaque semaine elle
vient du continent et troque ses talons
de femmes d'affaires contre une paire de
bottes en caoutchouc
bonjour à mon niveau
dans l' usine marianne vient superviser
la fabrication du produit phare de son
entreprise la bisque de homard
d'accord swiss et des têtes entière on
utilise dans la bisque la carapace va
apporter un côté torréfié et va apporter
le vrai goût du homard cas une bonne
bisque la base c'est d'avoir une vanne
matières premières donc des carapaces
donc avec du homard bleu on utilise
également des parures de poisson donc
des poissons qui sont pêchés maximum
autour de nos côtes et qui sont des
poissons issus de bateaux de petite
pêche
dans la bisque pas un gramme de chair
donc seulement des carapaces
une fois broyés c'est la partie du
homard qui dégagent le plus de parfums
puis ces carcasses vont être incorporé
au reste des ingrédients dans cette cuve
un mélange d'eau de vin blanc de tomates
de carottes et des pis
après des heures passées à mijoter
la bisque encore fumantes et mise en
bouteille
[Musique]
il reste beaucoup teddy
ok
voyez c'est ça une belle beasts une bise
qu'il ya de la matière on le voit déjà
ses récents pour lui qui l'ont
plébiscité
une drôle de rencontre l'année dernière
mais entre-temps
c'est apprécié et qui surtout a du goût
donc dans dans cette démarche je
on veut avoir actuellement
grâce notamment aux crustacés la petite
conserverie a réalisé l'année dernière
un chiffre d'affaires de 4 millions
d'euros pour continuer à surfer sur la
mode du homard marianne cuit à des
cherche sans cesse de nouveaux débouchés
il y a cette huile de homard et ce matin
un nouveau produit que marianne va
tester avec sa responsable marketing
ont ces jolies déjà ses premiers premier
point le plus important c'est que ce
soit mon tués lors qu'on puisse goûter
la couleur est superbe et des perles
rempli d'huile de homard
la texture est bonne on s'aggravera main
sur reims en croquant et ensuite ça
fonce à fond en bouche on montrait bien
ça explose rien mouche
ces montres vraiment le goût l'huile de
oma
les consommateurs actuellement sont
beaucoup plus un plein à cuisiner à
prendre le temps de s'approprier un
produit et perd c'est un produit qui est
très festif là moi j'imagine très bien à
noël vous ouvrez une huître vous mettez
un petit peu de perles amis de homard
c'est magnifique pour l'entreprise ce
nouveau produit est aussi une affaire
rentable ces petits pots de 30 grammes
seront vendus environ 8 euros
contre un joli lot matière c'est comme
d'autres
d'autres produits comme le caviar ou la
truffe
l'entreprise fournit aujourd'hui les
rayons des meilleures épiceries fines de
paris elle exporte aussi à new york
dubaï et tokyo
sur le port de groix la boutique de la
conserverie organise des dégustations
pour convaincre les touristes en visite
sur l'île
celui où
alors c'est très bon mais je regardais
mais il ya un pour mille dollars et
combien de
30% domaine
ces touristes originaires de charente se
laisseront eux aussi tentés par l'huile
de homard et les arguments de marian
gruia des
télés madame donc voyez vous avez
utiliserez recettes comme ça vous pouvez
après chez vous à refaire parfait voilà
on se rappellera de gros seins c'est
quand même des produits du terroir
artisanaux quand même pour la plupart du
temps quand on va dans une île on essaie
de leur livre les gens de nombreux
policiers chinois roma singer a voulu le
dire et cbs5 je pensais 8 euros et 40
centimes s'il vous plaît
merci
[Musique]
non
dix ans
mais courageux sont sortis affronter le
crachin sur le marché de roscoff
parmi eux il y en a un qui vient chaque
semaine patrick jeffroy chef étoilé est
un enfant du pays dans l'est à roscoff à
l'endroit magique
ou capitale
de la pêche de crustacés en général il
ya énormément de courant il ya
énormément d'agde nutrition riche en
petits poissons coquillages et donc les
hoba reçoit en ce qu'il faut pour se
dorer 1 et donc ça fait des beaux
animaux une très belle qualité avec
beaucoup de goût vraiment et les
meilleurs selon lui ce sont ceux de
claude le petit artisan pêcheur
sa fille claire vend ses homards pêchés
juste en face dans la baie chaque
mercredi matin sur le stand familiale
bonjour
ils sont rangés près de prêt à partir
alors voilà voilà voilà déjà au marquis
qui vient des péchés parce que regarder
l'antenne elle est aussi longue que la
que les homards quand il sort au vivier
la première chose qui commence à mort
parce qu ils se mangent entre eux ce
n'est pas un problème pour eux
de manger des copains eh ben ils
commencent par les antennes qui traînent
derrière eux qui va donc dans les
billets il commencera à croquer et c'est
comme ça qu'on repère
si les homards sont restés en vivier
[Musique]
derrière l'étal patrick est comme chez
lui le homard c'est sa spécialité le
crustacé a fait sa renommée il lui a
permis de décrocher deux étoiles au
guide michelin alors il le regarde avec
les mêmes étoiles dans les yeux on va
prendre une grosse grosse femelle qui
hélas cette grosse semelle c'est presque
un char d'assaut pour moi c'est
construit comme
c'est tellement cuirassé c'est tellement
et puis sous celle là elle est très
belle en plus on regarde et on dirait
que karl lagerfeld a habillé un petit
peu la décorer lalanne avait de la
bijouterie partout elle est très belle
ça fait partie de ma vie ce sera parce
que moi je suis cuisinier breton j'ai
toujours travaillé ses produits depuis
bientôt 50 ans même 50 ans chez vous
c'est beaucoup d'affinités que ce animal
ce joyau des océans patrick jeffroy lui
a toujours donné une place de roi dans
sa cuisine en le sublimant dans ses
plats
castello bon jeu pour la voir demain
adoma
[Musique]
carantec et ses îlots de granit
à quelques kilomètres de roscoff
seulement accroché à la falaise se
trouve le restaurant gastronomique
du chef j'ai froid
[Musique]
dans sa cuisine à l'heure du coup de feu
l'odeur du homard embaument toute la
pièce
c'est omar t2 auteur d'un énorme at elle
pas peur
ça a beaucoup poussé c'est un animal
comparé à la langouste qui est très
suspects envers clos marche c'est
musqués
c'est un peu comme un gibier
chez patrick jeffroy ce homard est la
star incontestée de la carte alors le
chef va le parent et comme il se doit
ces choses là on va refaire en purée
c'est l'envol furent aux chips ouakam et
copeaux avec tout ça voilà et puis on va
faire une sauce aussi avec les caravanes
1 d'accord voilà on va attaquer
première étape la cuisson et les sources
de tous les dangers s'il ya bien une
chose qui met en rogne notre chef breton
c'est un homard trop cuit
robin 500 grammes lowe's et boum ont
purgé le haut var l'eau se remet à
bouillir prendre l'été limite à tout on
sort le homard est l'intérêt à vous de
prouver une tv on sent les ovales on le
met dans de l'eau très froide avec des
glaçons l'âme s'il faut on arrête la
cuisson au stop this
après la cuisson donc le homard a pris
cette belle teinte rouge couleur il faut
alors le débarrasser de sa carapace
précieuse elle aussi
on jette rien donné en mars que la baule
à décortiquer un très joli cuisson on a
coupé les carcasses
ces carcasses quand heroes this il
apporte vraiment un parfum puissant de
du homard de chez nous que le homard
canadien n'a pas mais vraiment je n'ai
rien contre leur manque rien parce que
c'est un beau produit de la mer je
respecte tous les produits de la mer
mais celui ci a une caractéristique ans
même avec un écart était un caractère
vraiment
cette
[Rires]
voie là vous voyez donc là on rajoute
des oignons des poireaux delahaye des
échalotes les oignons de roscoff des
échalotes du pays de l'est du pays 1
j'insiste beaucoup là c'est
ce que le chef ajoute ensuite et on a
terminé c'est un peu son secret à peine
avons nous pu apercevoir des tomates un
peu de curry et une pointe danis
le mélange va frémir ainsi une trentaine
de minutes
ça sent le homard
puis patrick jeffroy commence son
travail d'orfèvre le dressage du homard
un lit de purée d'artichaut des pétales
griller des fleurs et tout un bouquet
d'herbes aromatiques
le homard est en train de revêtir son
habit de fête
le homard c'est un petit peu comme le
champagne
le champagne c'est un moment de fête je
dirais que le homard c'est pareil il ya
encore des clients il ya très peu de
temps il ya quelques jours qui nous ont
dit
c'est une immonde y c'était une auto
logis alors bien c'est un grand mot mais
ça fait plaisir en temps
[Rires]
au centre de l'assiette le crustacé est
sur son 31
pour les fins gourmets qui ont les
moyens de se l'offrir son goût reste
indétrônable
pourtant sa consommation de masse en
fait aujourd'hui plus que jamais une
ressource fragile
il faudra veiller sur lui et sur les
quotas de pêche pour assurer sa survie
pour qu'il continue d'être le plus
apprécié de tous les crustacés
[Musique]